[Musique]
si vous ne verrez plus les nôtres cohen
de la même façon après avoir visionné le
documentaire intitulé marianne et lemond
mots d'amour east maria
le film suit cohen après son départ de
west manche où il a grandi sa vie
bascule lorsqu'il s'installe sur les
hydra en grèce il y rencontre l'amour de
sa vie dans norvégienne marianne il n
véritable beauté solaire marianne il n
pas respirer à la nôtre cohen de belles
chansons tombe dans le royaume et ce au
nom de marianne qui selon le
documentaire s'intitule est à l'origine
comme moyen
[Musique]
mais ce film déboulonne certains grands
mythes en pleine époque de
contre-culture la note cohen le charmeur
et est dans les faits un homme à femmes
et sociable qui multipliait les
aventures grand dépressif comme sa mère
on apprend aussi que ces épisodes de
crise sur les hydra et est alimenté par
sa consommation de lsd et de speed
portraits s'étalent sur 50 ans et
parfois troublant après leur agonisante
séparation à la fin des années 60 les
notre coin et mariani l'aisne sont
restés en contact tout au long de leur
dit tous les deux sont décédés en 2016 à
trois mois d'intervalle
le film va jusqu à nous montrer marianne
sur son lit de mort tandis qu on lui lit
la dernière lettre que lui a fait
parvenir la nôtre ce documentaire et du
réalisateur nick broomfield qui s'était
auparavant intéressé à whitney houston
et à kurt cobain saluée par certains
critiques de film prendra l'affiché dès
vendredi
ici tout est fait depuis mai radio
canada n'ont rien